one of the things that Carl Jung said
that I thought was really interesting
when he was talking about the eatable
situation and Families I never forgot
this
so the eatable situation roughly
speaking is when I lay out the classic
story is when a child is seriously
overprotected usually a male child by
his mother now the reverse can be the
case and it can be a female child by the
mother and all of that but I'll just
talk about the classic case to begin
with
now what Freud observed was that there
were usually not very good boundaries in
families like that and so the
relationship between the husband and the
wife was either strained or non-existent
and the wife would often turn to the
child to be what she isn't getting from
the husband and so there's a great South
Park episode about this a wonderful
South Park episode where they where I
don't remember that horrible little guy
is that that's him yeah yeah yeah and
his mother brings in the dog whisperer
to train him and it's a brilliant it's
brilliant episode if you want to learn
about Freudian the Freudian eatable
situation you you watch that you've got
it down cold because she brings in this
expert who then she wants to have an
affair with so that's a boundary issue
and he basically separates her son from
him and and and imposes the same
discipline on him that he would impose
on a bad dog although he also trains the
dog's owners all the time because maybe
it's not the dog
maybe it's the owner there's a horse
whisperer movie - about the original
horse whisperer that does a beautiful
job of laying that out - because he's
very good at fixing problem horses and
unbelievably good at diagnosing
psychopathology on the part of the owner
it's he's got a gift for it but anyways
what happens in the South Park episode
is that the dog whisperer gets Cartland
yeah straightened out and he starts like
dressing properly and doing his homework
and and the mother is pursuing an affair
with the dog whisperer but he's
professionally keeps his distance like
he keeps boundaries around him and then
he leaves and then the first thing that
she does when he leaves his bride
Cartman basically out of doing his
homework so that he can accompany her to
I don't know a fast-food restaurant or
something like that and so the reason
she does that is because she's lonesome
and doesn't have anybody else around and
you know maybe she's also deeply deeply
deeply terrified that if she helps that
boy grow up he will leave and she'll
have nothing you know and so mothers who
don't have something say outside their
infants not merely their children are
more likely to fall into that and it's
no wonder you know you've got to think
that through and lots of women really
most women really fall in love with
their babies you know and so even if
they start growing into larger children
that can be threatening because what
wouldn't that when the child turns into
it when the infant turns into a toddler
that the infant is dead the toddler is
there now and you can radically
interfere with that process that happens
all the time all the time that's the
classic Freudian eatable nightmare and
that episode is brilliant bloody
brilliant it just nails it and some of
you've been in my personality class and
watched from the documentary crumb and
that's another staggering exposition of
exactly that kind of pathology anyways
one of the things Jung pointed out so I
knew this guy once who had a mother who
basically was trying that trick and she
had lots of she was very smart and had
lots of tricks up her sleeves and
there's just no way he was going to go
for it he rebelled at every possible
moment and he basically became I would
say somewhat hyper masculine in response
which is a which is an interesting
lesson with regards to the hyper
masculinity that boys often develop if
they're raised by single mothers because
they tend to go one of two ways and he
just fought her at every step of the way
and it didn't happen but one of the
things young said which I loved and you
can really see this in the chrome
documentary is that the eatable mother
basically entices the child says look
here's the deal you don't have to do
anything but you don't get to leave but
if you don't leave and you don't do
these difficult things then I'll take
care of you and the child has a choice
all the way along there I mean obviously
he's outclassed in some sense but it's
not as obvious as you'd think little
kids are tough and they make decisions
all the time and so Jung thought about
it more as a conspiracy then as
something imposed on the child by the
mother and I really
it's actually a conspiracy between
mother father and child actually and I
think that's a good way of looking at it
even though it's really rough because of
all should you hold the child
responsible well yes but judiciously and
not completely because then if you deal
with someone like that as an adult and
they're trying to escape from it you
have to go all the way back and figure
out how the hell it happened and then
they have to adjust they have to figure
out where they opened the door like
inviting a vampire in because they can't
come in unless you invite the bit you
know so don't invite them in because
once they're in they're really hard to
get rid of and they'll take all your
blood so that's a cautionary tale